millions of miles from Earth in the icy
gloom of deep space an alarm clock
should bring europe's comet chaser back
to life for the last two and a half
years the Rosetta spacecraft has been in
energy-saving hibernation as it catches
up with chairman of Gerasimenko a two
and a half mile wide lump of ice and
rock later this year it would orbit and
then land on the Comets surface
anxious moments for engineers at the
British company astrium who helped to
design and build a probe it's
interesting enough if you like to to
actually design build launch a
spacecraft but then see it travel around
the solar system for 10 years to get
where it is now is is just something
else never before have scientists
attempted to land a probe on a comet
traveling at sixty thousand miles an
hour the comet has almost no gravity so
the lander will use harpoons to clamp on
to the surface there it will study the
plume of gas and water vapor that will
erupted from the surface and trail
behind as the comet nears the Sun
Rosetta has already survived the
asteroid belt between Mars and Jupiter
sending back spectacular snapshots but
the trickiest parts of the mission are
yet to come and they start with a
deep-space wake-up call Thomas More Sky
News